Now that you know how to create
an arbitrarily complex nested layout,
it's important to understand
that they don't come for free.
Once again, the resource constraints
of the platform spoil the party.
Inflating complex layouts
can be expensive,
potentially impacting the performance
and responsiveness of your app.
So there are two good
rules of thumb to help.
First, keep your layout shallow and wide,
rather than deep and narrow.
That means you're better off
with more siblings and fewer children.
Because it's never as simple as that,
you also want to avoid
having excessive Views.
In the most general terms,
that means your activities'
full hierarchy should never have
more than ten nested Views
or over 80 Views in total.
That probably sounds like a lot,
but let's open up
the Hierarchy Viewer tool
in Android Studio
and see just how quickly
that can add up.